[Music]
uh
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool breads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hmm delicious long sip it's a great uh i
have some fizzy water today how do you
not choke with the sipping then
what do you mean it's fizzy water it's
like it's bubbles and you see it yeah
you can did your parents never teach you
how to drink
they didn't get around to it they think
it was fizzy water i thought the whole
thing what's the first thing when you're
sick you're a sore throat they have you
drink like seven up or spray it's easier
you don't like you don't like twirl it
you don't like sip it in like that don't
use your silly wine tasting terms
hurl
yeah well you know let's see if he
weighs as much as a duck uh we're gonna
be talking about a lot look
yesterday we were live on air and there
was a shooting happening in arlington
and my general policy is
don't talk about those things until you
get more information statistically the
early reports are usually wrong and they
were way off uh and uh now of course for
a lot of reasons the media wants to
memory hole a mass shooting at a school
four people were shot wow
and usually they of course well of
course they wrote it mom's demand action
we're politicizing this before the
bodies had even assumed room temperature
and as part of of course for the mission
statement with the show we want to want
to talk
with you about what you can do to
protect yourself and what solutions
there possibly are it's always tragic
when it happens thank god nobody died
but it is important to understand why
the media is saying nothingness yeah
yeah it's a figment of your imagination
we'll also be talking about the new
james bond film yeah i'm excited about
that the debt ceiling
we'll do it very very shortly and uh of
course the new dave chappelle uh dave
chaplin's parking controversy again oh
well good yeah good for him you mean for
telling jokes yeah ah
that's correct comedy yes yes once upon
a time well it used to be allowed back
in a simpler day we were allowed to have
involuntary emotions like laughter uh so
my my question to you is um
what do you think we're gonna see as far
as the media coverage
on arlington they haven't been covering
it at all this morning and now they're
going back to donald trump and the
attempted coup which also by the way is
pretty interesting when you compare the
bail set for this guy who shot four
people on school grounds
versus the bail set for uh
kyle rittenhouse or versus people who
have been held for indefinite amounts of
time for trespassing yes trespassing a
very serious experience no it's the it's
the greatest insurrection in uh american
history well what happened get it right
trespass yeah get it right it was the
most viable day in american history
don't ask questions other than the
bombings uh by the way before i get
there dave uh sorry dave
cheryl day
i'll explain to you uh
i had a long day yesterday and it's uh
but i just don't want to be a downer uh
gerald how are you i am well sir i'm
feeling better good for you you don't
have the covet either that's great i was
disappointed i thought i was paying my
dues that's probably why you feel like
such crap we have uh quarterback garrett
what's going on no no kovid no
so far so good i'm hesitant about the
the vaccine and everything yeah yeah
he's dodging all that he's three
quarters hesitant
uh also looks like the mugshot of the
next mass shooter so let's be careful
keep an eye on him we love you walther
don't send anything don't worry leave
you and uh dave landau is here you can
follow him on twitter and he has a show
coming up actually a weekend at the
orlando improv october 15th through 16th
how are you sir good ahoy ahoy uh yes
october 15 16 orlando improv that's
where uh the disney place is oh really
okay and today is going with the uh run
dave mc that's correct and i even have
the matching shoes
i figured why not start off the day
with a little bit of racism no not from
us
no that would never happen oh
but from
someone here uh who
may surprise you a father yelling at the
a person of color uh boyfriend
grammatically person of color makes it
so hard black boyfriend okay yes it does
sounds really racist
poc is right next to pos where it just
doesn't make sense yes no absolutely
right it's not a good idea aren't we all
people of color
no no we're all people we are all pos
because we're all people of shades
oh my god or the other meaning of that
yeah well all of it we are all look what
i am saying here is genetically superior
yes and that means all of us genetically
superior therefore no one is genetically
superior
equal we are all equally people of
shades and [ __ ]
just to be clear yes so just when people
say you're making right no no i believe
that people
black white yellow red right and we can
do the johnny mathis black
white
yellow red no matter that's what he
sings about a child is born about jesus
christ being born uh by the way i was
also gay johnny oh really did you know
that gay and set like a track record i
think in college for a hundred meter
dash so running after just other men i
mean if he wants you they are not
getting away they tied a penis to a
stick like he used to do with the
character
very effective instead of a rabbit it's
just a cardboard cutout of carlo
montebond
whatever gets to the end
i thought it was a strata so
asian dad i just i'm just ruining the
league boyfriend of his daughter's
roommate for
not wearing a mask in the dorm just
watch this video
okay sorry you didn't wash your mask you
ain't got a hair get closer okay
close your mouth wear the mask
deal with english
did you read english no i'm actually
reading english okay you don't read
english then you should go back to your
country man i don't know where you're
from
is this a joker policy statement let
she looks away what do you want her to
say
i'm not talking to you guys
so this has like 15 million plays or
something like that
i don't know 30.
13 13.
show me who you are
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah it's like he's auditioning for a
movie he's just not going to get the
role in like take it down a notch well
you say that because obviously look
there's been a spat that of course now
that they're no longer the useful pocs
the asians there's been a spat of
anti-asian uh hate crimes committed and
some suspect that this was actually just
an elaborate leak for the upcoming
remake of falling down which makes oh no
we actually have an alternate poster
[Laughter]
i love how this guy's making fun of his
english yeah in poor english you know
what i don't know what about
the breakfast scene in that movie where
he's in the uh you know fast food
i understand wanting mcdonald's
breakfast so bad you pull out a gun i
get it yeah
but they're like that's rules are rules
rules that's when it was shut five
minutes over yeah you could have come in
ten minutes earlier yeah but
unfortunately you were waving a gun in
traffic that being said if they don't
make your sunday look like the picture
well it's out of my hands
yeah that's true nothing i can do uh
what happened to the uzi you know it was
a good 80s gun yeah i don't use it
anymore it's incredibly ineffective what
there's a reason yeah but it looks so
cool keanu reeves used it in the matrix
he brought it back
yeah oh okay in the building well it
turns out all you need to dodge it is a
little bit of wire just like julie
andrews and peter pan what a great film
it's like we're in a it's like we're in
a simulation
okay you've really thought this through
so
uh
i like that quote it now to compare it
to life yes
that's my favorite i think it's a glitch
in the matrix right oh my god it's such
an original thought please leave my
house like i haven't heard it for 20
years oh yeah no we are in philosophy
first semester at uh connected economy
right where's my uzi
i'd like to point it in my mouth because
it's ineffective yes
it is that's why i have a toe trigger on
my shotgun so uh let's move on to are
you kurt cobain
i'm kidding his wife killed him
go on
and banned okay great
right now that's the sound of we're
already demonetized what are they gonna
do well i think we've all heard that did
i ever tell you the story you know when
they called me can i just i don't want
to go rogue right here but the vox
apocalypse happened you know before they
created we talked about this yesterday
that yeah the industry sometimes known
as the crowder rule sorry oops uh when
they called me youtube after the vox
apocalypse and they were it was me on
the phone they were reading from a sheet
of paper yeah right so i see me being
talked about everywhere and senators
saying i need to ban them
and i'm going like oh my gosh this is
getting out of control there's stock you
know alphabet google their stock price
takes a nose dive they release these new
guidelines and they call and they start
reading off of a sheet of paper you know
after having reviewed your content we
believe here at the you know reading
this whole stock letter and i this is
when i had i thought i might be having a
heart attack i think it was an actual
like panic attack i just because i
thought oh my gosh they're gonna here we
gotta remove the channel everything and
create a new rule even though we've
already been told that we haven't broken
any rules so the room started spinning
and i swear to you and i lay down and
i'm like oh gosh okay and then they uh
finally get to we have decided to
officially demonetize your channel
[Laughter]
sure that's okay
oh okay oh sure yeah great oh yeah oh no
you speak english that's the only time
i've ever heard that voice say go back
to your country yeah wow
while in america yeah it's like only
only a redneck has said that in that guy
go back to your country go back
go to my country they shove wood chips
up your thumb
yeah that's cambodia right now
no
that was a japanese in chinese the chef
wood chicken i know it's a very creative
form of torture and tells you that their
militaries have too much time on their
hands
should have been like i was wearing a
mask but until you walked in i was
pleasing your daughter
oh oh now you have potty mouth i scared
yeah now you praise me oh yeah oh now
you have potty mouth nothing like a
perpetuating original stereotype oh see
there's no proof to this this is how we
really talk
no proof at all
it's just so amazing if i was that kid i
didn't like say an l say a word with an
l correctly and i will put on my mask
correctly okay conjunction junction
what's your funk i speak a king english
and i'm only bringing it up because he
brought it up i'm sorry he made fun of
his english say little league and i'll
wear a mask for the next five years
better yet read this live ad for
colloidal silver
uh he started it i'm sorry
no but it's funny because it's like you
get called racist where it's like all
these things are based
on something that's real
that people from hong kong pronounce
their their l's and ours differently
right my mom's french canadian she never
uses plurals properly i don't understand
it everyone here knows she will never
include an s where it's required right
and then she'll add it where she doesn't
need to she'll be like well i have to
son
okay and she'll but then she'll say oh
i'm but tonight i'm going to order
shrimps oh my god stop well technically
it's multiple shrimp i guess i mean i
wouldn't got tacos with her one time and
she took the tortilla off and she was
like i don't like to eat the skins
i love francine
well michigan's the same way were they
add s to everything yeah it's like i
work at forts i went down to walmart
yeah they used to be kmarts yeah uh you
know i committed some arsons yeah
no that was correct it was yeah
that is true and detroit i mean
yeah it's rarely one arsenal so here's
something else dave chappelle let's talk
about this i think yeah dave chappelle
is in hot water and of course uh um i
haven't had time to watch it uh i wanted
to watch it last night uh but he's
catching a lot of flack for going after
the people or just really making jokes
about of course the taboo topics and
this is how you know something is
actually risky there's even discussion
potentially of netflix maybe pulling it
what i don't know how true it is
i think that the
what would likely happen is they just
won't renew
um come on it's because it closes anyway
after the comedy central thing dave
chappelle people don't know that dave
chappelle uh was not paid and they owned
his likeness a lot of people don't know
this that comedy central was a really
raw deal wow so he was very meticulous
with his netflix deal so even if they
decide to pull it they have to pay him
anyway so it's in their best interest to
run it we'll get to some of the jokes
that of course uh have caused some pearl
clutching here's a clip comedians have a
responsibility
to speak recklessly
sometimes the funniest thing to say is
maybe
remember i'm not saying it to be mean
i'm saying it because it's funny let's
play
are you ready
right now some guy's at home watching
one he's not even a wearing mask go back
what country are you from i'm worried i
actually opened for him at that theater
like oh five congratulations right after
you're very proud of yourself actually
absolutely oh yeah oh yeah i mean i
don't really know like nor macdonald
said that uh dave chappelle was uh you
know uh i think he called him like the
god of comedy he said he's the ghost and
and dave chappelle uh did this in
tribute to norah mcdonald so you have a
guy who people are trying to cancel
right now dave chappelle uh epoch uh of
course uh honoring a guy who was
canceled for the last three years of his
life yeah absolutely then extra
cancelled once he died yeah apparently
uh you know he sexually assaulted people
by saying folksy things yeah
[Laughter]
so dave came out dave chappelle came out
so we're gonna say day like we're in the
first name based yes uh one of the
things that got him in trouble was he
said he got to diagnose with covid but
didn't even get the sniffles
and people got really mad about that
that happens well for yeah well yeah he
was
he talks about in the video where he was
in a room you know for days yeah just
watching and the tv and he said he kept
seeing videos of black people running up
and just like punching asians in the
face and hurting them and he and he just
kept thinking like you know that's
exactly what's happening in my body
right now
dude that is
he's acknowledging what's going on yeah
he's comparing it to his own blood it's
a perfect joke and of course
not saying it's right
that's the kind of thing he'll say
hilarious uh what do you say he said he
also has so i have these because again i
did not get to watch it last night
usually we might do a live uh watch
along here this week or next week with
you guys he has his female friend who i
guess is a comedy writer
really there you go
if she was going to the woman's march
and she re
she replied i hope those white [ __ ]
get tear gassed
[Laughter]
uh
i guess he beat up a let you makes a
joke about beating up a lesbian in a bar
but it was self-defense because he
thought it was a guy he said i tenderize
them titties like chicken cutlets
i wolf the task of toxic masculinity out
that [ __ ] but he talks about ice there
and this girl he's just talking to being
polite and this dude steps between him
and then at some point in the
conversation realizes she's a woman and
he's like you're a woman yeah like and
he's just it's so honest and anyone who
acts like that has not happened i know
right and you're like oh that's a that
happened to that happens daily and i
have very few
human social interactions on a daily
basis outside of this studio if you're
being honest there are lesbian couples
you see where you're like how's that not
a guy there's just no penis i just don't
understand it that's like i am i am
repulsed by men okay attracted to women
okay so i want a chick uh who ratchets
down her tits and shops at orvis i don't
understand it if i were gay if i were
gay i wouldn't be picking
the boy george's of the world
i would be picking the most masculine
look and i get it i look i get you but
i'm just saying it is it's this is why
it's funny to people who are not
lesbians or gay it's weird it's
confusing because you're dating a girl
who looks like john goodman playing dan
connor
you know for linda
it's like that's not a woman that's a
lady in a heart hat smoking a cigarette
and a flannel and it's like that's my
lady yeah it's my lady
girlfriend i'm sure when you go back to
the original isle of lesbos that's what
they looked like no
they're all sitting down sucking down
marlboros and wearing painters pants
yeah nobody's ever uh uh looked up in
the you know the naughty sites real
lesbian
we get in trouble for that aren't i no
you're not gonna get in trouble he's
like let me see uh uh essentially
heterosexual sex
and of course that brings he's gotten in
a lot of trouble for uh again
the lgbtq the alphabet community
i guess they didn't take kindly to his
sorry not sorry apology but he makes he
made a point wrapped in a joke saying
that empathy is not gay empathy is not
gla black empathy is bisexual it must go
both ways that's nice
that was good and he's saying that the
whole thing with punching down he's like
well sometimes you do punch down in
comedy you punch up and everything but
he's talking about how he's jealous of
the
lgbtq community because like you guys
have made these enormous strides right
in this short amount of time music i
couldn't help just think that if martin
luther king was like now just put on
some booty shorts and rub yourself with
baby oil and get up on a float right
he's like we could have it's like if
they just had some booty shorts back
then we could have ended slavery a
hundred years earlier absolutely and
he's just making the point of like how
there's this massive progress in this
community in such a short amount of time
and of course yeah he's being attacked
for it and it's like
can we just leave jokes at jokes at some
point like
not everything's going to be to your
taste it's not just going to be punching
up punching down just
stop i think dennis miller said once he
said like every nothing is off limits in
comedy except the helpless so in other
words if you're taking aim at let's say
like a
down syndrome baby that's not going to
go over well no it's not it's not for
the same reason people are mad that you
know the institute under fouchy you know
killed dozens of puppies people like ah
you know we're not big fans it's
off-putting that being said i certainly
wouldn't say that the lgbtq community is
helpless at this point it's like it's
like super mario on the flower there's
nothing you can just star they're just
completely invincible you're not allowed
to criticize them whatsoever this is not
a community right now where they're
acting as though people insult them
consequence free yeah and he he had a
story i remember dave chappelle it was
back when he was he kind of wasn't
really doing stand-up but talking about
you know his specials and it almost kind
of got sort of lenny bruce-ish um and he
talked about a guy playing this card
game when he was a a kid on the oh yeah
yeah find the red card and he said
notary card monty three card monty
that's it yeah see he noticed the red
card was bent and so he thought okay i'm
going to be able to to get this guy he
only had 60 60 to his name he said put
me down 60 that is the card and it
wasn't the right card and he realized
that everybody else in the street was in
on this game they were all being tricked
right it was a double cross and he
started bitching about it like the game
is rigged you know he was talking about
he was screaming about it and the guy
got up grabbed him dave chappelle tells
the story you can find it on youtube
grabbed him and was about to maul him
and saw the fear in his eyes and he said
he felt his kind of glaze it's kind of
his his stare glazed over and turned
soft and he said never get between a man
and his meal and he made the point he
said because to remove a man's ability
to provide his effect his livelihood is
to remove his it's the same as killing
him yeah and that is something that i've
talked about he understands that and
that's why this guy
especially as someone who has had his
livelihood removed from higher ups
progressives at viacom and comedy
central people who tell you that we need
more diversity hiring who told him at
hbo why do we need you right they see
people whether you're minority or not
whether you're lgbtq or not as useful
tools for them
of which they'll dispose he said he had
his livelihood removed and it is the
same as killing someone that's what
modern cancer culture is if you remove
someone's ability to make a living
that's a serious problem especially for
something that is absolutely not only
under protective speech at least in this
country it's not in canada it's not in
australia but um certainly defensible
under the guise of comedy and i think
you're going to see more of this from
dave i get it i get the spelled one
after kenneth stones i get that dave
chappelle has got you know was honoring
saint george floyd and i get that
he's not right about everything right it
doesn't matter the fact is if you let
the mob come for this guy they will come
for you right and we've talked about
comedy being kind of the last bastion of
free speech like the last hope to
maintain free speech and the the role
that comics play in the society and if
you think that that's you know just
being a little bit kind of you know
exaggerating being a little over the top
just look at what they're doing with the
vaccine mandates now about taking
people's ability to make money away
right you have to have this vaccine or
you no longer have a job what do you
think that's going to do to thousa not
not
tens 20s hundreds of comics that can't
say this stuff but thousands and
thousands and thousands of people who
can no longer make a living for their
family people don't understand this when
they say well really what's what's your
line on this end really is it a vaccine
mandate where you can't work or really
it's your where someone says that you
can't tell an offensive joke just so you
understand we are talking about with a
vaccine mandate removing someone's
ability to work to provide for their
family we are talking about when you
demand a special be removed and you call
up every club and this happens all the
time and you say hey don't book this
person you're removing their ability to
make a living for their family do you
understand that as far as every war
waged ever
up until
maybe the 19th century
that was enough
do you realize people just fought for
land so that they could actually work
really hard and till the soil and
hopefully if they became a sedentary
agrarian society provide enough to get
their family through the renter and they
would kill you if you stood between them
and their turnip crops do you understand
that taking away someone's livelihood
was enough to go to war that's why
people ward and we're so far removed
from it because we live in this life of
convenience that we go oh well you know
what if we just take away his ability to
uh provide for his family it's well it's
not like we're not killing him no that's
enough
yeah well and in this story chewie tells
uh tells a story about a transgender
friend of his that commits suicide
and it's not to ruin the special for
anything but it gets a little heavy
obviously but when you look at that it
also shows that everybody is an
individual just because you feel
strongly about something or you don't
like anything or you don't like what
somebody says
that person was a huge fan of his comedy
regardless of what he said right people
don't have to fit into a box of what
they're told to be and that's the
problem now everybody thinks they have
to fit into this certain area and be
angry at these other things you don't be
an individual calling a place and trying
to get somebody like i don't call
everywhere kathy griffin works and go
look
i just think she's terrible and no one
should see it like there's no
you have every right sir you're the
140th call today
sir i've been telling the manager all
day but it it's it's just no we
you have no right to take that away from
people in this country and it's just
getting exhausting as a comic because if
you write comedy around the idea that
you're not going to offend somebody
you're not writing comedy you end up
writing the uh daily show with trevor
noah yeah it's true or yeah that's good
or stephen colbert
dancing with uh no you're like it's
dancing with vaccine needles that's
hilarious oh i understand it do you
think we could maybe do something about
you know big pharma
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you guys brought pfizer suits
i brought my moderna we're supposed to
have a meeting about this you have to
let me know there's just a black janitor
and a johnson and johnson suit
leans in off camera
it's just like where do you guys get the
ghost stuff
oh i see the irony i just wore this
every day i'm a fan
you tried the baby oil so um my name's
just johnson we're sheet of flavors we
wanted this rashida slade by the way
just and the point here is not the
hypocrisy like i've said in the past hey
look no coverage of the mass shooting
we're gonna get to that in a little bit
this is not the hypocrisy it's that
watch these clips
you know rashida tlaib who was out there
fear-mongering about coven and certainly
if you look at michigan and the governor
and the shutdowns where you weren't
allowed to go to a nursery when you play
plants uh it's always confusing when you
use the same term like what are you
talking about you're talking about uh
the place where i entrust complete
strangers with my infant
with my infant offspring or that section
lows that i never go to
the one place i don't want to go to or
the one place i have to stay 100 feet
away from yes exactly for crying out
loud
the aboriginals have 50 words for snow
you can't give us you can't give us
something else for nursery
by the way i speak english
oh people who say every snowflake is
different is a liar that's impossible
it's impossible it's ridiculous they're
all different no it's just look how many
there are you don't know that
have you seen every single snowflake
ever
yeah there's no proof why don't you take
those videos off youtube
[Laughter]
that's a good point and we will review
the information yeah
that's fair handsomely thanks lady at
twitter whose name sounds like vagina i
can't remember her name
i'm horrible with names i just remember
it sounds like uh i don't know i think
dolores yeah it's molva okay so rashida
uh explained on camera
the only reason as to why she actually
wears a mask is she doesn't usually wear
a mask she takes it off until she thinks
the camera's on here you go
oh my bad again
oh no oh no
oh i thought you were like
one unmasked guy because i got a
republican
uh oh
cracker did she say cracker or tracker
um i heard cracker i heard crackers you
heard what you wanted to what do you
think she's a tracker or cracker truck
what's a republican like is there a is
there a republican following her stumps
going like
she was here recently yeah
i don't know you're not really tracking
somebody if you're standing three feet
from them
around you're not like having to track
the down anymore right like she said
dead honky
whoa
that's an actual restaurant that was
renamed after they were funneling money
to hezbollah oh yeah that was the sheesh
yeah yeah where they were like uh turns
out they're terrorists and i'm like well
i still enjoy the chicken and rice stuff
but it's so tasty i'd eat my own hand if
it was covered in that garlic sauce but
it appears that they blow up a 747 and
they got good chicken they're not
sending that much money back no not
enough to
kill a couple people
you choose themselves yeah it's suicide
bombing good
that's not a good tag
well they need to work
suicide bombing good today our specials
we'll polish our chicken uh slathered in
our 52 virgins and spices
i can't imagine what they do to the food
there i'm still eating it it's delicious
by the way this is something so it's not
that she's a hypocrite she's clearly not
afraid just like nancy pelosi just like
governor whitmer that's the point that
matters here
anyone out there who is more terrified
than rashida tlape and nancy pelosi and
gavin newsom and governor whitmer and
every single democrat who tells you to
be afraid
is an idiot you're a stupid person
that's the point here especially because
this member of the squad has a long
history of this remember a couple a
couple of months ago i believe we have
the clip she was caught dancing uh at a
wedding do a doing a very xenophobic
warrior princess uh calling sound here
you go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
can you stop
that's pretty good oh i don't like that
noise no nobody likes that anyways well
that was in early august that's that's
when we were seeing the spikes all over
the country i mean that was so reckless
yeah yeah i can't i mean i can't believe
that
okay i see what you're doing there yeah
opposite day
um
yeah that was that was that you're right
that was in wayne county was a coveted
orange zone i lived there at that time
yeah that's insane went for biden
even though it was called for trump live
well we were on the election stream from
all local outlets i'm not saying we did
everything remember all the local
stations yes or at least at least a good
amount of them you were covering it too
in detroit they said yes oh yeah wayne
county for tremendous makes sense oh
yeah i was covering it that night well
they called it's a cnn called i mean so
many places called it and then
afterwards they say well the mail on
ballots and you're like well come on
you're an entire news agency
you already were saying in the lead up
uh you know the mail-in ballots
obviously but then you said uh it's not
right there's no mail-in ballots won't
make up for this gap right and then like
well i'll call it for
point is we don't know anything
oh yeah the point is i think it's all
legitimate
it was legitimate most secure
election in history looking like ballots
all those democrats were wrong yes in
2017 they were wrong about the election
security stuff i mean i think it's just
important to say and i'm fortified i
think that all future elections should
transport the ballots in real red wagons
and coleman coolers it's basically i
think it's oh no wait sorry they said
remember they said that wherever we were
live quarterback were like what's the
coleman coolers and the excuse
afterwards like it's camera equipment
like hey we travel with tens of
thousands of dollars in camera equipment
yes every week have we ever once put it
in a coleman cooler uh no we usually put
water in there have i ever once said
rolling pillow can cause get that the
hell out of here can we get one of those
flyer wagons yeah
that's super secure yeah i just bought a
a canon camera is there a way i can get
some uh uh hot ice dry ice yeah yeah
yeah i'd like to rattle around when i
transport it yeah it kind of the worst
thing is possible to break the lens yeah
i'd really just like to put my 9 000
lens in a handkerchief at the end of a
stick and walk the railway tracks can we
do that it's common practice i'm having
beans
just a couple of ballots in there yes
don't forget by the way while we're
talking about the squad
uh
uh aoc took her mask uh off she put it
back on for a picture and then took it
off right after so again this is the
squad the people who talk about how we
need the lockdowns and of course people
should have a
more significant social safety net so
that the lockdowns are it's all
self-perpetuating and she's not afraid
she doesn't believe what she says
[Applause]
rake i feel like sideshow bob is going
to step on it by the way one thing that
i know
one thing that i noticed is right early
on in that video if you freeze frame it
that looks like the triggered lesbian
means look at that look at that oh she
transitioned is the transition complete
maybe it's a little goatee there oh
i hate her face someone needs to study
that and the galapagos
oh it's just so weird
okay
really quick really quickly before we
move it just look they're not afraid
they don't believe any of it do you
honestly do you believe that here's the
thing i don't believe that they believe
it right no
i'm not sure that i believe half of
america have bought into this at this
point no i don't know if it's just
keeping up with peterson's love i have
no idea at this point are people
genuinely terr
are most
30 20 year old american males females
genuinely terrified for their life right
now but were you guys ever i mean we we
for two weeks we said like okay we'll be
careful and we yeah at that point when
they were saying you shouldn't wear
masks we said actually if you're sick
here's how you can make your own mask if
you have to go to a place of work then
we just said oh they're gonna keep us
locked down we're gonna do an entire
month and we did two a days we were
never afraid of this i don't think you
should live your life in fear and
certainly not versus something like this
you should be prudent
whatever whatever i have to say here but
right i just don't know anymore if i buy
that these people are terrified i don't
think so either i mean you can look at
people's actions to determine you know
really what they believe and honestly if
we see them doing this behind the scenes
and they're like oh it's because of
republicans oh it's because of a picture
oh it's because we're on camera right
now it's like okay i mean really really
you want me to believe that this is a
problem nancy pelosi going for a blowout
come down to chinatown saying all that
stuff you really want me to think that
this is something that you are deathly
afraid of yeah oh by the way something
that we are going to get to here later
today uh the covet vaccine some new data
that's come out and of course i don't
know if you know this but vermont is
seeing its worst surge
ever
ever or fish fans yes yes
also they have the annual juggalo
meeting i don't even know how that works
gathering they got that i think they're
gonna have to get do they have the
gathering this year i have no idea are
they getting invaded by canadians how
hilarious would that be if the juggalos
didn't have their these are insane clown
posse by the way oh okay if they didn't
you don't already know meet up because
of covid
that's what scared them off
it is what happened last year yeah no no
way they did not do the gathering i
don't believe that we're getting that's
wrong we're getting off the beaten path
i don't think so we're talking about
juggling i almost just i almost this is
i shot myself because i thought that i
saw maggie gyllenhaal out of the corner
my eye on the honor oh thank god it's
just an allegra commercial oh good
so a close off-putting woman
like i told you every time we've been on
a theater ship appears on screen my dad
makes an audible oh
and then after like the third or fourth
close-up people in the theater start
catching on hey hey hey
sexist
she always has this face yeah yeah she's
always like she just like she's thinking
about how much prettier her brother is
yeah
it must be tough
so uh this this script smells like [ __ ]
so that's a yes so i'll say yes i'll do
that
let's just people haven't asked me to
cover the debt ceiling i look i don't
i don't want to have to but
former vice president joe biden made
this comment yesterday and i think that
we can sum this up in really two phrases
i don't think we really need to argue
about the state of our country or
direction we're going so take it from
him
raising the debt limit is paying our old
debts
there's nothing to do with new spending
or what may be coming this year or other
years
there's nothing to do with my plans on
infrastructure or building back better
both of which are paid for but they're
not even in
in the queue right now
come again stupid look
it's paid for just like we were talking
about this yesterday we we provide all
of our references at
louderworthcrowder.com you guys can hit
the link in the description yeah we try
to be as transparent as possible but yes
do i need to really arg is anyone going
to argue with me that donald trump was
tougher on china than joe biden i think
if we're going to talk about common
ground have to be some basic facts here
does anybody actually believe
that borrowing increasing our debt limit
so we can borrow money to pay previous
debts as we incur new debts have nothing
to do with each other if you have to pay
off do you honestly believe that paying
off your previous credit card statement
that you can't afford in no way affects
your upcoming credit card statement i'm
sorry to be reductive but what the [ __ ]
you're paying off your credit card with
a higher interest credit card right it's
insanity it's like there's nothing well
you can keep doing that forever because
eventually you'll get the zero percent
financing right
sure oh i got some points back yeah yeah
exactly yeah it's it's just saying we're
going to acquire more debt and that way
we'll have less debt right well that's
that that's that problem we're trying to
get to the 1930s
if republicans don't raise the debt
ceiling we'll have our credit rating
downgraded like oh why does that matter
we won't be able to incur more debt
who has worse credit in this country
than our government
we're crying out loud we're one step
from the fed being western unions yeah
the most offensive thing about that is
it was shot on a set and they didn't
even take the time to make the window
shot seasonally correct that's that's a
spring with all the flowers behind them
like just somebody put like dead stuff
oh come on why isn't he in the oval
office is it just too many sharp corners
he doesn't know the difference
they have
the nerf corners president kamala is in
the oval office thank you very much
she's just decorating it for herself
he's been banished if nerf corners in a
just they have a mesh net six feet
around the fireplace yeah just uh
first aid kit every three feet what is
the five-year-old in here no it's it's
the president oh much worse than a
five-year-old gosh
i look i don't know if you want what
else do you want me to say
we are so far gone where trillions is a
rounding error and we're acting like it
has nothing to do with our ability to
spend ourselves into oblivion it's
absurd at this point it really is okay
uh moving on to this uh of course you
know um the last james bond film yeah
jimmy bond is uh released i believe
today jim uh and i think we have like a
shortened teaser for people who don't
know and then uh of course there's a
story now demanding a female james bond
but here we go
james bond
so you're not dead
hello pew i missed you
james
you don't know what this is
nope
oh it's going with a female pilot
uh that's a poc okay oh i'm sorry it's a
poc i hope she has the stretchy
maternity suit
you know that that's double seven i
don't care it is
shut up and of course now there's been
this demand uh look i don't care if
james bond is black or white i mean
we've talked about this really there are
plenty there's no shortage of black
action heroes yeah uh i mean black
action stars you have people like will
smith denzel washington not to mention
characters like sheffield this is not
something where there has not been equal
representation so
i think that james bond should probably
be true to the origins but it's not
really a big deal but there is a demand
and outrage that they make james bond a
female character
which of course would never work for
reasons that are obvious which i won't
get into today because i've already
covered it and i want to maintain what
small piece of my soul i have left but
we actually do have uh uh uh
titles now that have been suggested that
have been floating around the studio
for the next james bond installment
should it be a female james bond which
brings us to this week seven plus one
[Music]
you forgot
the chamber
this is seven plus one
female james bond titles okay yeah and
you guys can play along with us in the
chat we'll be taking your chat a little
bit later at mug club uh number seven
female james bond titles from william
sonoma with love yeah people are looking
forward to that one i think it's a good
name she's gonna have some nice
tri-clad
pots
place you never want to go again i don't
even know what it is
female james bond titles number six you
only knit twice well that seems a little
tone
but if it's a hobby it means
vagina hats for the parade yeah yeah i'm
going to give you number five and i want
dave to take the next two but uh number
five female james bond titles uh the spy
who
never called me back james bond is
always complaining he is always on the
road she she never calls well i mean no
she's complaining that he doesn't call
well now she will the whole mission is
screwed yeah yeah it's done the mission
is for cocted uh
female james bond title seven plus one
dave number four uh never say that dress
makes me look fat again yeah you're
taking your life in your hands with them
you certainly are dangerous that's going
to be a slaughter female james bond
title is number three license to bake oh
license to bake well look it doesn't
mean that james bond
james bond can't be multi-faceted it
doesn't mean that she doesn't have a
license to kill she just also makes
scrumptious cookies two things can be
true or killer cookie how do you think
how do you think she seduces
the evil male agent
high on a windowsill yes that's right or
and another reason some argue that uh
you know female james bond wouldn't work
as as opposed to the dance of seduction
that's required for a male to make
himself attractive to a female mate
which is really sort of the the back and
forth the tango of love the female james
bond would just need to show her tits
briefly and then of course get all the
information she needs so it's a little
bit
tougher it's true it would be a pretty
short movie it would be a pretty short
give me the codes it would just be like
oh i'll give you the codes it would just
be a slurping sound and then credits
just be just be her coming up throwing
her sweaty hair back going uh he's in uh
he's in the he's in the bunker there he
is
may have your gun yeah oh yeah take it
i'm not even in the mood
uh someone plus one female james bond
titles number two her majesty secret
cervix well that's actually uh we that
was a high school huh
watchable uh and the number one female
james bond title doctor no means no i
said it i said it several times of
course the plus one uh one that uh is
just a working title yeah from russia
with hpv this has been this week seven
plus one
[Music]
can only women get hpv no no no men can
get it uh
catherine say to jones man can we get it
riddled with it how many times no yeah
catherine zeta jones apparently cigar is
whiskey and pleasing catherine's eater
yeah right yeah it's anyone's guess what
a great diagnosis though
it's from your wife's
also no one finds stuff out like a woman
though we you're very sneaky so
sneaky well that's a negative stereotype
yeah coming from a woman women are
sneaky which implies dishonest it's
better than saying they all have hpv
well i wouldn't say they don't have hpv
just this spy this this particular she's
not allowed to confess promiscuous
spiders
not in california thanks for
discouraging people from sharing
well women there's a stigma you can keep
an hpv secret if you're a woman if
you're a guy you kind of got to explain
yourself i would assume you would think
so yeah because they're like what's that
you can't be like i don't know that's
just rhino later i have no idea
no it's gross no it's just ew
looks like cauliflower yeah it's
disgusting
[Laughter]
i'd like you to leave oh by the way what
am i uh are we telling people to
subscribe to the podcast uh audio
podcast or what are we saying uh today
all of the i was i have no idea all
right well listen it's a live show
monday through thursday so you can tune
in at 10 a.m eastern that's the best way
you can hit the notification bell uh
because subscriptions don't really mean
a whole lot that's the best way to tune
in we're gonna do another hour of show
on the mug club um uh and what's the
other thing i was going to say to people
oh smash that like button if you can
anyone watching live right now
just hit the like button just like
like that just hit the like button
you don't have to do it though i'm not
gonna i mean what it's like we're not
going to force you it's not going to be
a mandate yeah we're not going to show
up at your door and say like the button
yeah love it also by the way you know
what i can understand if you're if
you're like button hesitant because that
like button
it was created
using uh dead fetal tissues oh
i didn't want to be a downer but my
point is i really wish youtube would
stop too and there's no need like why do
you even need fetal tissue for a like
button it's on a screen it almost seems
yeah unnecessary it's really like you
know it's like a 50 50.
you'll get it yeah who knows because
there's a dislike yeah there is a
dislike who knows
if we were joe biden former vice
president joe biden giving a speech
there'd be like a 90 10 chance we could
get a different ah yes
disables it yeah of course or reverses
it thankfully he's so popular he is the
most popular [ __ ] most votes
ever
so uh vermont right now for people who
don't know you know this is something
that's interesting um when people talk
about the vaccine
people talk about how effectively it's
working yeah uh
there are several different things you
have to look at okay you have to look at
okay the vaccine the studies in the
vaccine itself right the efficacy
ratings okay what do you have we've
talked about these from mayo clinic and
we have some studies here that came from
that have come from israel quite
recently yeah but you also have to look
at the numbers at large now vermont uh
the most vaccinated state in the united
states also important to note vermont a
very rural state they don't have
incredible population density no um 69
of them are vaccinated so they're based
at the number that people talked about
with herd immunity yeah they now have
the highest caseload
on record in the state oh
right now doesn't seem to mesh 70
vaccinated low population density more
cases right now in a rolling average in
vermont than ever
hmm
so we'll get we'll get to the point
we're talking about the vaccines and how
long the immunity lasts
isn't that doesn't that raise some
eyebrows but this isn't the first time
we've seen it like you said with israel
and then we we had some information that
the misspeak apparently misspeak out of
australia even though he was quoting an
article that was written i mean right
both must have gotten it wrong right no
idea what really happened there yes but
this you don't have to think about it
well i try not to
and by the way this is this is local
vermont news right here uh almost i
believe almost i think it's like 95
every county has been labeled high
transmission in vermont by the cdc
and this is something look the reason
that this matters is because to this day
still the cdc blame and and former vice
president joe biden blame the
unvaccinated
there is a clear message that is coming
through
this is becoming a pandemic of the
unvaccinated and just confirms that this
really is a pandemic oh right now on cnn
that we're still in a pandemic of the
unvaccinated ah we just missed it right
there on cnn they were saying that they
were authorizing pfizer's authorizing
vaccines for i think under 11 years
they're seeking approval from the fda
actually have a note from our team they
brought that in okay seeking approval
from the fda for kids age five to eleven
yeah and if you live in california that
means uh it's mandatory right as soon as
it happens for your kid to go to school
mandatory because of your governor look
behind you there was your line in the
sand uh this is something else too we're
talking about vermont
even cnn and we've talked about this
with the vaccines we've talked about the
mayo studies cnn i was just reading this
i believe yesterday or the day before
had to acknowledge i'm going to read the
quotes from cnn okay from cnn which they
are quoting
qualified scientists the israeli study
and i believe some medical journals so
this is something where if i had said it
banned
i am
everyone here understand i am quoting
cnn the paper being quoted is cnn with
cnn being the paper quoted
when new england journal of medicine
should give you some cover as well
they're a little known publication right
but even the point is if cnn is starting
to acknowledge it yeah
it must be really bad so uh they
acknowledge the waning protection of the
vaccine these are direct quotes the
waning appears to accelerate after the
fourth month to reach a low level of
approximately 20 percent
in subsequent months
cnn quoting
the new england journal of medicine
still quoting
these findings suggest that a large
proportion of the vaccinated population
could lose its protection against
infection in the coming months perhaps
increasing the potential for new
epidemic
waves
how how i don't
in other words like yeah well you have
the vaccine to reduce any surges right
and to reduce any new epidemic waves and
to immunize you uh you know against the
virus okay so that's what we're doing it
for well yeah except for the fact that
uh if you take the vaccine your uh your
protection will get under 20 and that'll
lead to more surges of the virus i don't
i can't well
how long does it take is it several
decades for that to happen no no no no
no yeah a couple few months a few yeah a
few months today's tuesday we're talking
friday right and then you say
hey hey cnn i got a question real fast
how long does natural immunity last uh
it's a good question
i can't answer that why because you're a
stranger is it longer than four months
that's all i want to know at this point
by the way so here's the cnn is back to
the story i don't know if you wanted to
pull them up at all and see if see what
they're saying about the 5 to 11 stuff
oh let's see what they're saying about
authorizing children hey look sanjay
gupta got rid of his [ __ ] because i'm
just going to say i assume this is that
that's
sort of weighs in on this and says we're
authorizing it because they've just
heard from the company so far so you
know and it's for emergency it's not
that appropriate
not normal fundamental concern is i
think my kid's fine i don't think my
kid's going to get sick why do they need
to get a vaccine it's it's a argument
that we said you know we hear over and
over again but i think particularly so
with young kids
and the pediatricians do need to make
the point that it is
rare for obviously young children to get
sick but it can happen uh and if it does
happen
so stick them we're gonna yeah
some parents have expressed concerns
that uh you know that their children are
highly unlikely to be affected uh uh and
that's true and they've also expressed
concern from the new england journal of
medicine that the protection wanes down
to 20 percent after only a few months
and so uh i would say that i understand
but break yourself [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they just pulled
in an ice cream truck
i love how they just say rare i'm not
going to say numbers here because i know
that that could get us in trouble
no the number of kids under 17 who have
died from covenant no the breakthrough
case is very very rare dave very rare
very rare just rare though just rare and
we have a pandemic rare doesn't mean
never
no means 20 protection like
oh they're saying we want to authorize
it no first off you want to let me make
this let me let me let me make sure i
have this about right okay all right
so we have a uh virus disease okay uh
with a death rate a mortality rate which
i'm not allowed to quote because big
tech will be furious right but we can
say because uh cnn was allowed to say it
that the hospitalization rate including
everybody even 90 year old would include
that entire pool is 2 or less so we have
a virus like that that has allowed us to
uh obviously uh enact emergency
authorization of a vaccine that had not
been approved despite being through
several other trials beforehand right an
mrna vaccine and of course this
emergency use authorization it's only
allowed to be used if there are no
effective all available trees
and then we mandate it to people in the
expectation telling them that it will
immunize and then switching that to the
word will actually protects against uh
under the guise that it will reduce the
surges in hospitals and prevent people
from being infected this is mandated and
now we are looking at the state with the
highest vaccination rate that has their
highest caseload when we have a
significant portion of the united states
vaccinated we have more cases this
august than last august and the study
says you're down to twenty percent after
a few months do i have that right
yes banned
and then people say one word god then
says well your freedom your freedom well
your freedom what about my freedom to
not die
first off
i'm not sure that you should exercise
that freedom it's your call
i think you should just exercise might i
interest you in my shotgun toe triggers
it's just so sweet well get the vaccine
if you don't want that's fine that those
are great things yeah
you don't want to die you know i i think
you know i think you should vaccinate
your children with vaccines that you
think are trustworthy i am very very
pro-vaccine we all are uh well i think
most people are i i think uh i think
saying look it's very very very rare so
let's do this
so the doctor has never ever said that
think about that right nobody's like oh
there's like there's like no chance
let's do the surgery that's never
happened it's always like don't worry
about it we'll cross that bridge when we
you know yeah it's never just up until
now well even here in the cnn article
they say and uh one theory is that
people who are vaccinated uh may be
engaging in more social activity which
could uh which could be the reason that
they make up such a high percentage like
first off
if a vaccine works that could not be
less relevant has have those words ever
been written yeah about the measles
vaccine rubella polio have they ever
been like well you know what the reason
that all the vaccinated people from the
measles vaccines that category the
reason that they make up 90
of uh those with current measles is
because well you know what they're
they're going out in social situations
of course they wouldn't this is the only
time that that's taken into account
it doesn't make any sense to me too and
the argument of the vaccines that you
just guys just made basically it's like
oh you don't you don't question your
kids having to be vaccinated to go to
school why would you question this and
i'm like
i don't know i mean i would say it but
maybe just pull up the numbers maybe
pull up the numbers for this stuff i
mean i can't i can't say these things
also that other vaccine was around while
doc holliday was still alive right
that's when a doctor was like you should
uh smoke less yeah ah here's some
cocaine notice yeah exactly there's some
heroin for that cough yes exactly it's
made by bears yeah don't worry so you
know you can trust them everyone has a
patent on this is a rich man
listen i'm gonna go out on a limb and
say that i am for vaccinating kids
against things that will kill kids
yeah
yeah just i'm not gonna say anything
else yeah because i can't yeah and i'd
get you in trouble yeah you absolutely
would i think kids should get the flu
shot
the standard flu shot no i'm not gonna
make no cuts look we haven't
no comment i don't look look look we had
something i couldn't record the
voiceover for today because it ended up
getting really complicated but i spoke
with people on the street this last week
yeah
and people who supported the mass
mandate said well this is because it's
really uh dangerous for children we just
look we've talked about the numbers how
deadly the flu the normal flu is for
children people it's like 0.85 in the
last two seasons from the cdc that's
almost one percent the standard flu so
when i spoke with people i said well do
you support mass mandates every flu
season they said why and i said well
because the flu is actually surprisingly
lethal
and i won't say it now because i don't
have the numbers in front of me but you
can guess whether they are more or less
lethal than other diseases by ooh i
don't know a ten time multiple you can
guess
um and they said hmm
well that's a good point i hadn't
thought of that and then some of them
said well i guess we need to mandate flu
vaccines and masks every season and some
other people were actually thoughtful
enough and saying ah you know what maybe
we do need to actually look at our
liberties and freedoms and it's not the
thing one thing too with masks it's not
only a net positive there's nothing in
this world that you do that doesn't have
any type of unintended or potentially
negative consequence yeah and breathing
to even if it just means improper use
breathing through the panties that you
stuffed in a glove compartment and
double-sided taped around your face
is not necessarily going to be
protecting you the way that you think uh
a fresh n95 mask in a controlled
environment where no one is arguing with
the science that they are entirely
appropriate worn properly and let me ask
you this people out there who wear
cotton masks or who wear whatever it is
yeah moisture wicking masks what i don't
know anything i wear moist cotton you
wear moisturizers
wet masks don't break
you how many of you washed it on a
sanitary heat cycle every single time
uh no
honestly how many when people tell my
masks how many of you wear a new mask
every single time or wash it on a an
equivalent to a commercial sanitary heat
cycle every single time i have the
finest liquids
i use gas station bathrooms and public
drinking fountains ah yeah you know look
give them a little bath and then you are
protected and then i'm safe clean as a
whistle i thought it was like you know
getting stung by one of those things in
the ocean you just pee on it it's better
no yes that's not okay
yeah that's what george michael said
that's how he set them up he put a
oh my god let me fix it what is this an
r kelly mask so uh okay let's move on to
this before we leave the uh the
arlington shooting um yesterday that
happened no coverage by the way oh yeah
abc nbc cbsc and no coverage at all
uh thank god nobody died yeah police
arrested uh timothy george simkins for
the high school shooting he wounded for
ah okay
we're wondering why this hasn't been
covered yeah and there were people who
said this is the first ever black uh
math school shooter that's not true
we'll get some numbers uh and i will
tell you what i was surprised when i saw
the mug shot why because i know the
neighborhood yeah and the truth is this
kind of stuff happens or something
equivalent in the south china south side
south side of chicago
days go back
leroy brown yeah massive school shooter
all yeah
all the time and in detroit all the time
just not covered the reason the media
rushed here with cameras was because
they thought oh suburban area school
shooting yeah of course we're going to
before the bodies are even warm run with
the narrative uh now
i want to be clear there's some
information out there that we don't know
right yeah okay now the the reason we're
talking about is because the media
misreported this yesterday as a as
though they did know some legitimate
outlets reported that there were there
were deaths uh some outlets reported
falsely on videos that had been
circulating and i want to say that we
don't have all of the information here
but i'm going to make some inferences in
which i'm not entirely confident as an
exercise in just reading about what the
media is not telling you so it'll happen
in real time
uh the first here's the first thing it's
simkin's family the kid who uh shot up
the school yeah uh his family blamed uh
rather than apologize it was surprising
how they did not apologize when you
watch this entire clip they blamed
bullying well one does he was scared he
was afraid
there's a video that's all out on social
media and it shows that he was being
attacked
it wasn't just one person
that would attack him and bully him
taking his money
it takes us all
it takes us all to stand together about
this bullying it could have been a
situation where he took the other turn
and decided to commit suicide
what does that would have been way worse
than shooting four people we're not
justifying that
that was not right but he was trying to
protect himself it sounds to me like you
just justified it a little bit he was
trying he was trying to protect himself
when he went back home
got a gun came back in cocked it loaded
it went through the metal detectors and
shot four people yeah i mean as a a
parent though i mean i can understand
her stance of defending your child
instead of just jumping in and
apologizing yeah i can understand it
that it's like i mean i guess do you
think that would be afforded to white
parents of columbine or you know people
like if they came out and said ah my
son's right you people are just
overreacting
well the uh
there's a couple books on columbine
including uh one of the mothers that i
read and
you know they did in some ways like a
minister had a
a secret funeral for uh dylan and eric i
think the other ones i can't remember i
forgot their emails
but i uh
most offensives are still using hotmail
i know it's crazy i'm like oh you guys
haven't responded since 99.
what's going on i got ghosted it must be
y2k how was that lunch special i so i
thought um
i ruined this
uh wrote a book about it where
you do and there's actually a movie too
which is from the uh the view of a
school shooter's parents which is
a really fascinating character study so
it's like there is
a lot of layers that can cause somebody
this is somebody to behave like this i'm
wondering what is truly the symptom of
this or you know what's causing this i
said earlier i watched it and they seem
like normal people they don't seem like
they're
like crazy ghetto people or they seem
like normal i guess we have a
disagreement in the studio because i do
not have a whole lot of sympathy for a
guy who walks in and shoots four people
i don't know he's talking about that i'm
not saying i'm saying no you're saying
the parents are normal parents yeah i'm
not saying it's gonna be rough it's
gonna be a rough situation well there's
a difference between going to school for
them not i don't think for for him no
i'm i'm referring specifically to the
parents yes that makes me okay i agree
with that yeah and there's a difference
between going to school with the intent
to just shoot and kill as many people as
possible and going back in so it looks
like he shot an adult a student another
person was grazed with a bullet and
another person was being treated for a
fall or something like that so
right so he's not a great shot no no no
what i'm saying though is that there's a
difference between that like where maybe
it looks like you're going after the
person and then somebody should do it
away but that's different than walking
in and just indiscriminately shooting up
the entire school so i i definitely
understand that this is not this is not
columbine right now yeah but i don't
know i mean that seems like he that
seems like he has a problem with four
different people well one of these
things has no connection to the other
it's i mean their argument is he was
bullied i think the guy who had a
collapsed lung is an adult like a
teacher right right it's a teacher so he
was bullying him in the way maybe the
teacher jumped in was he made what was
he making him work on the railway tracks
what we have here is a failure to
communicate
i want to go get my glock like what do
you think was really happening the point
is no of course that's indiscriminate
pregnant lady got hurt and i got to
collapse lungs i don't know and then
people okay
i'm not saying it's good i'm just saying
it's not calling he fell down trying to
get the out of the it's columbine only
he's the worst shot like dave said no
it's true it is i i agree it is
columbine i mean this has been a huge
problem it and it wasn't this giant like
people talk about it was this the giant
thing in black communities where you
know i'm from the detroit area it wasn't
like this there was a lot of gang
warfare there was a drugs there well
i'll actually get to some stats that
might surprise you i would be surprised
honestly a lot of people are surprised
and that's because of the way the fbi
presents a lot of their crime statistics
so uh but i i do think though it is part
of the same thing there's something that
is happening there's a symptom only two
years
that's causing the statistics don't i
think what has happened is we have a
media with a 24-hour news cycle and let
me just say one thing that could be
that's something i'm incredibly grateful
for with this show your parents your
parents my parents your grandparents
their grandparents guess what they had
news three times a day a half hour that
was it you didn't need a 24-hour news
cycle and so guess what we have the
luxury of today where it's like well
there's not a lot of news to fabricate
let's do a seven plus one let's make
sure it's informative entertaining we
can have more conversations we can play
some games because we are not beholden
to selling fear we are not beholden to
making sure that you panic the truth is
crime has been going down consistently
until 2020 wonder what the wonder what
was different about what different about
that
what's one of the easy anomaly uh school
shootings make up a very very small
percentage of mass shootings yeah far
more of them are gang-related violence
and you'd be surprised as to how many of
the qualified mass shootings actually
happen at minority schools most of them
we're going to get to that in a second
and they're just not necessarily covered
uh this is something where a lot of
people have a perception that something
has really increased look this is what
happened columbine they said oh my gosh
these ratings are insane we're going to
continue covering mass shootings at any
given point they didn't used to cover
that even though they happened before
the same thing is look the reason that
they're talking about donald trump still
when did they used to discuss an
ex-president ad nauseam at length they
didn't they just realized that it was
unbelievable for ratings and cnn is
where ratings go to die it's just like
cover trump trump trump trump trump
cover mass shooting messaging we're
doing a car chase that's why the numbers
don't reflect that and here's something
again i'm making an inference they said
that this kid was bullied okay really
quickly can we bring up the mug shot
first
so there we go this is the mug shot now
the photo that was circulating was the
apb picture that's what you asked me
about dave and i said hold on a second
and there are a lot of websites that are
still covering with the apb picture
meaning there's you know all points
bolton where they were saying hey let's
try and get the shooter they're still
using that picture even though we have a
mug shot now
i'm making an inference by the fact that
the media is being a little bit
tongue-tied
not saying that this kid was actively
being bullied or actually the one who
was being beaten up in the video if you
look at the mug shot and keep in mind
he's a senior
we can't show you the video because
that's been removed from facebook or
youtube but i think we have some images
from the fight in question here uh and
if you do go and watch it
it looks a lot like the guy in the mug
shot and the other guy clearly does not
the other guy who's getting beaten up is
clearly lighter skinned clearly doesn't
have the same haircut and look anyone
can change a shirt but uh
it it matches
yeah not only that what else it's
obviously a senior beating up on a
freshman or a junior it's one much
bigger male beating up on a smaller male
beating the crap out of him yeah to be
clear it's not a fight it's an absolute
beat down
so i don't know that he's the one
administering the beat down but because
the media initially started covering it
with that narrative and then they said
and now they're being quiet
and this has been circulating if i were
to bet my bottom dollar i would say
looks like he's the one administering
the beating yeah and according to the
new york post as of about four hours ago
they were saying that the shooting was a
result of this fight right the fight in
that video they didn't say it was a
result of him being beaten up no no
the result of this fight really what
happened
we
in
the
a research department and the cousin on
facebook was basically defending uh
defending him as well saying no it was
because of bullying and everything else
and i think posted that fight video as
well right so well i mean a lot of
there's a lot of it that says yeah that
video is them one way or the other right
and the point is this the media doesn't
want you to know why this story they're
trying to memory hold this story
it was being covered we were there
yesterday remember david it was live
they were set and ready to have their
next 24-hour coverage
and they were still covering it once he
was in custody right covering it people
shot covering it incorrectly at some
networks and news outlets that someone
that there had been casualties at that
point covering it covering it covering
it oh he's in he's in custody and then
more about donald trump and the big lie
well what happened
the debt ceiling because people want to
hear about that that's the issue is they
want to memory hold us and so we
have to try and gather as much
information as we can that of course
mainstream outlets don't even want us to
have so if anyone out there actually has
some more information as to whether that
fight did happen that day yeah new york
times is saying that it did new york
post new york post is saying i had to go
to the second page of google reserve you
know the last time i clicked to go to
the second page of a google search
we're looking for hunter biden's laptop
ah well that's true
uh here's something else to keep in mind
guy did does anyone else disagree with
this guy uh shot up the school okay shot
four people at school regardless of why
okay
seventy-five thousand dollar bail kyle
rittenhouse two million um
not to mention yet some people i don't
even know if there was any bail set well
january 6. uh some people there was not
some people there was not and it's
trespassing
it was such a giant public thing and i
think they were like hey let's stop the
burning
yeah kyle i'm not calling it right or
you know what carl rittenhouse shot a
serial pedophile who repeatedly yelled
the n-word and was actually trying to
shoot him yeah oh yeah and i've gotten
himself against somebody wielding a
skateboard
let's just use january 6 people some of
them said without bail and you can see i
think brandon strzok had just got uh
disorderly conduct i think that's what
he just got he's the guy who created the
walk away movement right the game
movement it wasn't even proven that
first off it was proven that he didn't
even go in yeah
and it then they said but it was him on
camera you could hear him off camera
saying hey go in boys that wasn't even
proven there were some people who
claimed that it wasn't even brandon
straka and he just said all right you
know what i'll take the plea it's a
misdemeanor yeah
i mean how long were these people so you
have a kid now with 70 000 probably will
get out but might be out this afternoon
and then you have people the charges
aren't even felonies and they don't know
when they're getting out and there's no
due
process why why doesn't the left care
about a mass shooter to school
um
well because
i mean it doesn't fit that agenda
i think i would argue that we've come to
and i think that it's also i also do
think
on top of that though that there is a
difference between
the gun violence that's occurred in
low-income extremely poor neighborhoods
and the ones that are now middle class
and above yeah it's stranger it's
atypical yes it is it's atypical because
most mass shooters are not white
statistically to be clear you're right
it's atypical but the media cannot have
it both ways and say anytime it's a mass
shooter it's a white terrorist and then
say well the only reason it's being
covered is because it's a nice white boy
you're right that's abnormal that's not
common it's not usual for a primarily
like you said maybe middle class upper
middle class white suburban neighborhood
to have a mass shooting they happen
almost daily weekly in other areas of
the country it just isn't covered well
not any worried for the same reason
right and that's what i mean too it's
like one drugs money whatever it is that
oh no not for the same reason sometimes
people i mean that's it's a different
but yeah it is a different thing and i
guess that's even what i was getting at
at the beginning is what is the
difference between those two the kyle
rittenhouse thing i think we all know
it's just because it was public it was
the and it was such a politicized thing
yeah that they had to put a huge bail on
it because they were trying to keep
cities from burning i get that because
they want to crucify they want to
crucify that kid i mean he was the one
trying to keep cities from burning it
was on fire at that time oh absolutely
but you're not saying that's that was it
but it was from is you know
but i think it's the important point
because here's something that nobody
else is talking about right now how many
times have we heard this right well
we're speaking about the race issue
because they divide and conquer and
separate everything by race and so the
media went with this narrative for a
long time saying oh kyle rittenhouse
dylan roof look they were taken into
custody by police right so was this guy
yesterday we said oh i guarantee you if
they were black they would ne the police
would have shot them on the spot don't
just remember in case you've forgotten
how did dylan roof shoot up a church
james holmes shoot up a movie theater
and both live to tell about it
why is it that the police decide that
some threats must be extinguished
immediately while other threats get the
privilege of being some are active and
some are surrendering dumbass i'm asking
these as questions but i feel like we
know the answer
you're an idiot
is that the gun
doesn't matter this is who is holding
active threat versus surrender you [ __ ]
is the most threatening weapon of all ah
just look at the difference okay watch
this
alleged gunman kyle rittenhouse walking
away gun in tow as people screamed that
he just shot protesters
on the trigger telling the police
i think the answer to that is pretty
obvious and if you're looking for a
better visual illustration of the
differences between being black and
white in america i don't think you're
gonna find one yeah i think it's the
difference between one hands up going to
an officer saying hey look these guys
attacked me several of them with a gun i
tried to call 911. this is a loaded
firearm what do you want me to do and
the officer saying thanks get over here
versus a man after kidnapping his
children from the woman that he raped
and filed a restraining order reaching
for a knife and a floorboard one's an
active threat who wants to be stabby
stabby mr copman and the other one is
saying hey what do you want me to do
i'll follow orders yesterday we have
this kid who happens to be a person of
color turned himself in after maybe
beating someone up or not but we
certainly know shot four people and uh
surprise police didn't shoot him i'm
guessing he turned himself in and said
all right i don't have my gun with me
and i i just watched the cops kick the
[ __ ] out of a white guy in minneapolis
from uh security camera footage or body
cameras last night in minneapolis during
the riots because they were going by in
an armed vehicle and the white guy put
his gun down and they walked they kicked
him in the head while he was face down
on the ground with his gun away from my
point is wow it goes both ways if you
want to see racism in everything and not
that there is a loaded weapon not that
someone is actively not only resisting
arrest but attacking police officers
versus a passive surrender
if you decide that the only thing that
you see is race well then you might be
as dumb as john oliver who just rebutted
himself
and i love how the reporters said with
gun in tow yeah that's because it was
slung over shoulder facing down and
backward like yeah that is not a
threatening position it's almost as if
behavior matters more than anything else
it's not that black is the scariest
weapon out there it's that behavior
dictates how a situation will go every
single time cops will tell you that that
is the number one indicator of how you
will deal with cops if you have a gun
pointed at them or if you're trying to
get a knife you're probably going to get
shot yeah that's not that controversial
at all black white hispanic or even the
hong kong guy from earlier i'm scared
yeah i don't know you surrender to me
see what happened so
um
this is another myth right this was
tweeted out and was retweeted a bunch of
times uh that this is the first mass
this is the first black math school
shooter ever okay that's not even close
to true uh so dr peter langham he's a
researcher with the national threat
assessment center of the united states
secret service yeah found this these are
just some examples 2014 myron may shot
three people at florida state university
robert butler three people mil uh
millard south uh high school uh 2015
chris harper uh mercer 17 people at ump
um college 2007 nico tatum six people
mojave high school uh there are a bunch
of examples okay and let's also be clear
that only one percent of shootings that
take place at schools or gun related
incidents are mass shootings at all in
other words 99 of gun related incidents
that's it right yeah one percent this is
incredible because by the way the media
covers it you would think that almost
all of the shootings that happen at
schools are mass shootings right that's
that's all the number one thing is just
it's like oh yeah people are getting
into fights and shooting it's very
uncommon yeah and 64 of all gun
gun-related incidents at schools happen
in schools that are i know this is
confusing a majority minority meaning
that these schools are are where a
majority of the student population
schools that you would consider black or
brown schools okay let's just be real
about it 64 of those incidents occur at
those schools and you know what i've had
direct experience with this my aunt yeah
okay at denbigh high school in detroit
look it up she had to have her diploma
mailed to her because someone was shot
in the face at school my dad uh my uncle
sorry again at denver high school there
was a lady who was stabbed in the
bathroom for being back then they used
the term molado now they say biracial
yeah so they live it this this was a
common occurrence in detroit it's so
common that it doesn't get coverage yeah
and the reason that you need to know
about this is because they're saying
that this is an angry white man problem
right they're saying that angry white
men will take a gun and they will go out
and they will try and get justice on
their own whether it's a school shooting
a mass shooting whatever it may be
you're going after what whoever it may
be
that clearly is not what's happening
here but you know it's not just that
it's that they're not telling you that
at all right they're not telling you you
know it is an angry white man problem
statistically angry white middle-aged
problem suicide it's not even close yeah
i always have coffee messed up at
starbucks went to the bathroom and he
came in and he's just talking boom going
back in what males
middle-aged white males commit suicide
at an astronomical rate yeah it is one
of the most common causes for male i
think it's i don't have the numbers in
formula yeah it's more than anyone yeah
yeah and then uh
for teen for teenage black males i
believe homicide is like the number one
cause of death it might be number two uh
because at that point they're not
getting the heart hearts these brackets
it's staggeringly high my point is there
is a there is a typical white male
problem it's usually middle-class
working white middle-aged males and it's
not even close we don't talk about that
here's something else uh people have
been going with this right now that it's
it's a myth and this is so if they say
it again it's just like waving their
wand right there is nothing here it's a
myth that a good guy with a gun is what
stops a bad guy with a gun because at
first people would say well you know
what stop bad guy with a gun is a good
guy with a gun yeah and uh first off
before i even go on with this there was
someone saying yeah where was that good
guy with a gun this was being tweeted
out they're talking on cnn
oh okay yeah let me ask you how to get
taken into custody stupid
the cops are up with silly string so do
you want more good guys with guns or
just those racist oppressive police
officers i just want to make sure i
understand the rule book because i'm a
little murky
okay let's be how are they taken into
custody every single mass shooter you
can name at some point was taken in by a
good guy with a gun
i just believe that we need to give a
fighting chance to people who are not
police officers and statistically i'll
make this argument but now they're
saying good guy with a gun is is a myth
you know how i know that's not true
first off probably because of the people
who are saying it but the fbi crime data
suggests that felons killed
justifiably by civilians is 15 percent
higher than law enforcement so this is
what i was talking about yesterday right
it was like 2.2 million dollars from the
cdc but it was these were grants given
to people okay yeah and so some people
dove into the crime data i think this is
from the fbi unified crime report so uh
last year i believe this is 2020.
2020 or 2019
uh civilians killed
304
people uh who were in the act of
committing a felony okay 304 things 343.
did i say 304 yeah 343. sorry i forgot
to say the three yeah 343 uh civilians
were killed people who are in the act of
a felony yep armed uh or mostly armed i
don't know there are two different
numbers i think one is whether they were
armed one is whether they were not right
they were in the act of committing a
violent felony law enforcement 298.
civilians killed more violent felons in
the act of committing a violent felony
then the cops
that's a good thing here's something
else
let me give this to you i've talked
about this before people always throw
out the numbers and it depends on a
given year you know 40 000 gun deaths 30
something thousand gun deaths well a
huge portion of those right of course
are our suicide over 58 so it's usually
about 60 so now you lower it you're
literally looking at 15 to 20 000 gun
deaths per year but let's even be
generous here and use a number that they
never use 480 000 criminal uses of
firearms per year okay
and this is this is according to the
national crime victimization survey yeah
you know how many uh defensive uses of
firearms
2.1 million is the annualized
so 400 000 only 15 000 murders homicides
deaths right versus
2.1 million defensive uses of firearms
each year and the thing is a lot of
those uses of are never they never
require a shot no they require simply
having a firearm and the bad guy knowing
that you have it but even when shots are
fired civilians do it at a higher rate
than police officers you know people go
oh whoa so you think that uh you think
some guy with a with his firearm who
hasn't gone through police training is
going to stop some bad guy with a gun
pretty much
yeah well and this is the whole crux of
the argument
right well this is the this is the
argument right if you're going to stop
gun violence right in america the
policies that they are putting in place
will stop the 2.1 million they'll stop
people from defending themselves for
sure but they will not stop criminals
from continuing to break the law that's
been the argument the entire time you
can't get rid of guns criminals have
them i want the 2.1 million people that
did that or
put
2
one million instances to have a shot
right that's it and you're not hearing
that from no one's saying it's a
guarantee but it is a guarantee that
they don't even have a fighting chance
if you strip them of course it's the
right to basic self-preservation look
let me give you two scenarios and then
we're going to go to muk up here and
take your chat and i think play oh god
we're gonna we're gonna play steven no
sports uh apparently something with tom
brady who i guess is a quarterback let
me give you a truth i don't think i
guess i don't think that it has happened
or i think it happens very rarely
that a woman is in the process of being
raped going thank god i don't have a gun
right now otherwise this might have
gotten out of control i think it happens
quite often that someone finds himself
in a scenario where they realize and it
clicks
oh
if i only had a firearm right now this
entire scenario could have been
neutralized only it's too late that is
true
it is a lot but when people say oh the
risk doesn't outweigh the rewards
that's not true when people say your gun
is more likely to be used on you that's
not true the truth is
that
the risks if you don't have a firearm
you get raped you get killed you get
tortured defenseless you're a victim
the reward if you have a firearm and of
course are responsible with it and there
are more resources available right now
than ever in american history to learn
responsible uses of responsible use of
firearms and storing of firearms is oh
you might be able to have a fighting
chance against a rapist murderer you
might actually be able to exercise your
god-given ability to self-preservation
that's what it comes down to i know you
wish that there weren't any guns i know
that you wish that the people weren't
violent i know you wish there were no
mass shootings i know you wish you could
believe your magic wand but you can't
and so right now there are people out
there who have to deal with other folks
who have no problem infringing upon
their rights and they have one of the
hundreds of millions of firearms
wherever they are here in the united
states or across the world what do you
do do you allow the general population
the god-given right to protect
themselves oh this rape hurts thank god
i don't have a thank god i don't have a
mouse gun on me otherwise i really might
have been another statistic don't think
it happens a whole lot you can let me
know just making an inference here uh
youtube you know what i know you don't
like this and i don't like you piss off
[Music]
bye